The idea is that if you're,
if you fall into a chaotic state and
everything falls apart,
there's the possibility that
things can come back together,
including what you've just learned in a
new state,
and so you can conceptualize that
symbolically as the existence of the
dead father at the bottom of the,
of the chaotic landscape.
That's.
That's the proper way as far as I can
tell to think about it.
It's like there's something down there
that's capable of reforming and
reemerging.
That's it incorporates the previous
state,
but that takes it farther and you're not
going to find that unless you descend
into this chaotic place where it feels
like all order is gone while you
generate order.
It's going to be akin to the order that
you had before,
but there's going to be something new
about it as well,
so it's down to the bottom of the
chaotic state to bring up what you're
missing and that's one level of
analysis.
Another level of analysis you think is,
well,
that's also what you're doing.
That's what you should be doing.
In principle,
when you're going to university,
you're,
you come to university in roughly the
same status.
Pinocchio.
No,
you're a bit of a puppet and you're kind
of a jackass and what the hell do you
know?
And it's chaotic because you haven't
found your place in the world properly,
and I don't mean merely for career,
not that that's not relevant because it
is,
but it's more important than that.
It's because you're a historical
creature because you are a product of
history.
Unless you are inculturated properly,
which means you understand your past and
in the sense that the humanities can
allow for that,
then
you haven't been able to incorporate the
wisdom of your ancestors into your day
to day pursuits and that's gonna make
you weak.
That's the idea.
Anyways,
and so when you come to university,
this is what universities for it so that
you can go into the chaos and you can
pull something out of it.
That's truly a value and you can
incorporate that in your own personality
and that makes you much,
much stronger,
like literally stronger.
Not more educated but not.
It's not like you know more facts.
It's that you literally are a better
person and better means you can do far
more things.
You can articulate your that's.
That's something that's of crucial
importance is that you can articulate
yourself properly,
which is more useful than anything else
you could possibly manage.
Like if you guys come out of university
capable of making coherent arguments and
using language properly,
you're so powerful that it's ridiculous.
You,
you always,
you can lay out a strategy and pursue it
successfully and maybe the strategy is
actually oriented towards something
good.
Something that will actually work,
work for you and work for other people
as well,
and I don't really understand why people
aren't taught,
told this when they come to university,
is that your goal is to make yourself as
articulate in writing and thinking and
speaking as you possibly can because
that opens the door to everything that
you'll want to do in the future.
No matter what it is,
the more articulate person always rises
always because they lay out strategies
more effectively.
They lay out the reasons for doing
something or for not doing something
more particularly.
They convinced people and properly so
that they can grapple with potentials
that lies ahead effectively and they can
defend themselves when they're
challenged and so all of that is going
into the past,
into the chaos of the past.
You could even say and pulling up the
spirit that inhabits that from the
bottom and uniting with it,
and if you don't do that well,
you're defenseless in the case of in the
face of the tragedy of life and and then
then that's not so good because if
you're defenseless in the face of the
tragedy of life,
then you get way more hurt than you
would otherwise get and sort of the
people around you and then the
probability that you're going to be
resentful and bitter about that is
really hard because no one likes to fail
continually and then you get bitter and
resentful and then once you're bitter
and resentful,
well being,
being vengeful in mean is the next step.
It doesn't take much of a transformation
to move you from that place to the next.